merci j'apprends en marché à la plus
numérique y en a je pense qu'on peut
raisonnablement se poser la question
parce que le monde du numérique amène
vraiment énormément changements dans nos
sociétés numériques
c'est une vraie révolution dans la peine
700 des bouleversements absolument
énorme
on a inscrit ce que bouleversements au
niveau de l'économie
je vais site ici hubert airbnb mais elle
a bien d'autres qui sont en train de
bouger très fortement le marché
aujourd'hui grâce le monde du numérique
aujourd'hui c'est aussi les réseaux
sociaux facebook twitter et tout un tas
d'autres façons de connecter les gens et
qu'ils n'ont pas trouvé d'autres façons
de transgresser finalement une
hiérarchie qui existait jusque-là et de
bousculer un tabou en clair
d'interaction avec les alors les
systèmes éducatifs l'éducation en
général n'échappe pas à ceux qui nient
les riffs et on voit apparaître plus
tard nouveautés liées à cette révolution
je pense notamment à l'accès aux savoirs
sans me disent ici parmi les médias je
pense à tout un tas de mouk qui ont fait
leur apparition ces dernières années et
dix corps sert à l'université numérique
est bien l'oeuvre
je pense également aussi à d'hésiter
vous présidez qui se propage
si vous n'avez jamais une conférence
tech de ken robinson je vous invite à
aller les voir
des gens pratiquent également je pense à
simple aussi l'école à laquelle je
participe lesquels 42 qui amène qui
porte à une nouveauté sur le plan
pédagogique seconde numérique c'est le
monde dans lequel il faut grandir les
générations futures
il se trouve que j'ai une cousine à ses
proches son il ya les petits une petite
fille l'été dernier et pris globalement
satisfaits et elle qu'en ce moment en
train décide à prendre petit à petit un
marché a tendance à gonfler d'albums
jeunesse terre d'où l'homme à bercy j'ai
réalisé qu'il est composé un petit peu
de cas qu'ils fassent tout ce processus
d'apprentissage fonctions et comme je
suis aussi la voie vraiment énormément
plonger dans le numérique est
franchement un petit peu guide dans
l'âme
la solution idéale est venu
instantanément dans mon estime
ah mouck demo qui forcément par des
vidéos qui ont critiqué ou mais il
s'inspira de l'invité comment fonctionne
la pesanteur qu'elle voit que les forces
qui vont s'appliquer sur les différentes
gens pour pouvoir avancer car marché un
mot qui avait débuté l amour aussi parce
que c'est furieusement tendance en ce
moment avec l'égalisation père albert
qu'un petit peu partout joie vous êtes
aussi convaincu que moi on va peut être
essayer de revenir finalement sur
comment
alors tout d'abord avoir quatre marchés
pour lui c'est quelque chose qui a du
sens c'est quelque chose qui a du sens
parce que ils voient les adultes qui
marche aujourd'hui je me sens parce que
il est assis ils veulent aussi
d'explorer davantage
c'est quelque chose qui va effectuer
également sans courant
il va effectuer sont en cours parce que
on va lui dire ok présidente et ses deux
riches étaient ses avances et donc il va
par contre avoir l'information va voir
les adultes qui vont marcher autour du
lit tous les jours et il va pouvoir
engranger petit à petit ses différents
modèles des différentes façons de faire
qui voit autonomie il va essayer d
essayer autant et il va souvent se
casser la figure
il va faire ça en général même si sur
cette photo ici dans des parents enfants
jean faire c'est généralement de façon
assez autonome et en aucune manière il
manipulé en aucune manière diva est
grondé parce qu'il n'arrive pas à
marcher pacifiquement avoir des
encouragements
il va avoir les parents les proches
autour de lui qui sont toujours au final
un enfant va mettre le temps dont il a
besoin pour pouvoir apprendre à marcher
il va peut-être marcher à tirana qui va
peut-être marcher un an et demi passé
pain mais en fait c'est surtout pas
perdre 5 et 30 enfants ils arrivent à
marcher
on commence à se poser la question
pourquoi est ce que l'école soit elle
absolument là mais des jambes d'ensemble
même tranche d'âge et il veut leur faire
apprendre la même chose au même moment
sur la même durée
alors ce mécanisme
voilà ci fonctionne quand la marche si
ce vote en fonction
c'est tout à fait la même chose qui tire
vols
généralement lorsqu'on est plus âgées le
parent le parle ainsi de l'expliquer
c'est très compliqué quand même regarder
un guidon du vélo quitté sur la [ __ ]
et tu pousses ça marche tout seul je ne
sais pas si vous vous souvenez
comment vous avez partie de la règle
générale comprendre comment vous êtes
passé du moment avant pour après c'est
vraiment quelque chose
d'incompréhensible et c'est généralement
pas les explications des parents qui
étaient là parfois même au congrès un
petit peu facile on commence à trouver
les premières traces des stigmatisations
ensemble et henri général qu'est ce qui
a permis ce débile qu est ce qui a
permis au final d'arriver avec un
parfait puis l'eau c'est le retour
si on enlève les parents et les conseils
qu'on a pu recevoir c'est le retour
finalement du processus général cassis
naturel d'un partisan de ce processus
naturel l'apprentissage finalement nous
permet marché et on se rend compte que
rien en tous genres marché la même façon
parce que c'est quelque chose qui
fonctionne jusqu'à marge compris
chercher midi à quatorze heures et même
en fait on se rend compte que c'est le
contraire qui est en train de se passer
c'est à dire que non seulement l argent
façon mais même on se rend compte que le
numérique est en train de nous permettre
de nous rapprocher du système
d'apprentissage
aujourd'hui ce déphasage entre l'école
et entre les besoins
la société pour cette révolution de
l'école a été faite quand la connaît
aujourd'hui
depuis 150 ans elle a été organisée par
la commission fait en sorte de former
les gens les normes et de individualisé
de leur permettre de retrouver une place
par la société
dans le même temps les usines avec est
aujourd'hui sont cuits ces valeurs là
qui fondent notre société aujourd'hui on
a une société qui est dans les domaines
économiques services une société où ce
qui est important aujourd'hui ce sont la
collaboration
l'innovation la créativité des choses
qui sont complètement
je dirais aux antipodes de ce format
pédagogique de l'école à l'origine pour
preuve on a malheureusement il oblige
environ un tiers des classes d'âge qui
n'arrive pas jusqu'au bout
donc c'est bien qu'on a un certain
désamour c'est bien qu'on a un schisme
entre l'école et entre deux secondes 7 4
6 4
actuellement ça fonctionne en alors
l'école bien évidemment à chercher à
compléter le ce cap numérique commence à
prendre toutes races en deux mesures on
a vu tout à l'heure les mouches
je pense aussi aux tablettes avec là je
pense également au tableau interactif
qui remplace dans certaines écoles la
cré le tableau noir et en général on
reste sur le numérique minutes manquant
même outil qui permet de déployer
exactement la même pédagogie alors que
aujourd'hui au travers de nombreux
exemples on a tout un tas de nouvelles
façons d'enseigner qui apparaissent
grâce
je pense notamment à des parcours
individualisés des parcours
individualisés
ça veut dire que chaque apprenant que la
gloire avant des objectifs qui vont être
complètement personnes année on va
pouvoir enclencher nous demande qui doit
être complètement folle sur l outil du
coup on va faire complet de mon sens
pour la personne c'est à dire qu'on est
probable plus motivés si oui ou non on a
un objectif personnel
elle attire le parcours pédagogie je
vais partir la formation dont j'ai
besoin pour pouvoir atteindre l'objectif
donc on est forcément tout de suite
maintenant plaisir on va être aussi dans
un système où l'information est comme il
présente la formation trop présente
est-ce qu'on a encore besoin d'avoir une
classe de transmission de connaissances
et là aussi on a quatre ans d'expérience
technologiques existent pour sa lente
notamment au système de classes inversée
l'interaction avec le professeur réguler
pour transmettre la connaissance
mais pour pouvoir au contraire discuter
débattre de la connaissance qui a été vu
au préalable les idiots dessin numérique
nous permet de faire ça numérique l'eau
permet aussi d une expérimentation
si vous êtes familier avec les serious
games
si vous êtes familier avec les
mécaniques de bac à sable sont des zones
qui sont à peu près je vais fermer dans
lequel on va pouvoir mettre un agent et
innovant explorer va pouvoir tester leur
pouvoir essayer des choses il va pouvoir
finalement qui tout y est à l'intérieur
de cette zone d'expérimentation sans
trop s'en sortir avec éventuellement un
contrôle un regard externe de la parole
en cadrant autour pourtant là mais on va
retrouver toute cette démarche sont
venus dire leur charge
finalement pouvoir faire des essais en
cours pour faire des tests et dont on va
échouer forcément à l'autre on
poursuivra ce que j'étais en train de
voler ce que je change de me vois pas ce
que c'était c'était pas lui est notée 7
mg/l d'autres solutions de cheminots cgt
j'avais commencé on a aussi du multi
supports numériques aujourd'hui nous
permet d'avoir des tablettes ont permis
de voir un smartphone mais des
ordinateurs on peut faire ça dans le
métro on peut faire simple quand on peut
faire s'amuse à chez soi dans quinze
jours et de l'aisne
ça aussi c'est quelque chose qui
révolutionne énormément les pratiques en
termes d'investissements on a le
numérique qui nous permet tout une
longue hésitation et tout employé peer
review c'est-à-dire évaluation en
parrainant la qualification appelé
review vont permettre d'intégrer
naturellement le fait de se rappeler le
fait d'être évalué le fait d'avoir un
retour et se dire c'était beau c'était
baballe et de pouvoir recommencer de
façon sereine sans se dire voilà on
entre à l'anglais parce qu'ils ont mal
fait si vous avez déjà acheté un jeu
vidéo
pas forcément qu'elle tout le monde
en règle générale vous achetez pas un
jeu vidéo si vous êtes sûr de pouvoir
casser tous les niveaux et les uns après
les autres sans jamais vous trompez donc
encore acheter un jeu vidéo vaesken et
du challenge parce que à chaque coup
devant vous a débuté à chaque niveau
vous allez le faire elle ne rêve pas la
brève mais parce que non seulement vous
arriver
sous ce niveau ou alors vous trouviez le
meilleur choix le meilleur façon de
sanctionner ce nouveau et c'est tout
simple qui fait partie de notre attrait
beaux jours on a des dispositifs
d'apprentissage qui répliquent
complètement ce mécanisme là et qui vont
être des éléments très importants de
motivation des gens dans leur parcours
pédagogique le pierre-yves lui aussi est
quelque chose qui va contribuer
fortement à la motivation des apprenants
lorsque honda une note qui vient leur
professeur par ailleurs actuellement
oligarchique il ya un troll à présent
entre l'enseignant et apprenants l'a
souvent atteints en raison des jeunes
que les points de vue forcément de
partisans sont bien différents on a en
tout cas un sentiment ange soulanges
l'apprenant de rejeter à ne pas accepter
son propre échec par rapport à
l'immensité de la note le fonds de la
marine qui ne m'a donné par quelqu'un
qui a un ascendant bernard j le fait que
la note soit donné par quelques uns des
problèmes niveau qui sera un apprenant
qu'ils soient en train d'apprendre même
chose qui sera sur le même parcours
pédagogique que vous et le faire puisque
monsieur jean n'est pas qu'un seul de
tourner plusieurs participe aussi à des
marches d'acceptation de son propre
échec et ses propres erreurs et permet
plus facilement de les intégrer et de
leur proposer de nouvelles solutions
m plus pertinente et qui va remplir que
d'être les conditions pour passer au
niveau suivant
si on continue à raisonner en quarts de
l'unification enfin chacun son tour
le numérique permet dé formation de
trois jours lumière elle permet d'étaler
la même formation en trois mois le mini
mairie permet d'étaler une formation
tout au long de la vie dans la maison
alors son père d'un petit peu plus près
finalement qu'est-ce qu'on a là on
retrouve les principes la logique de
notre apprentissage naturel qu'en
découle tout à l'heure avec la marche on
retrouve aussi le thème de ce qu'indique
ce les six best on a moins de
contraintes pour plus de liberté en
amande passivité pour un cursus et avec
des avions qui sont beaucoup plus actifs
qui sont beaucoup plus impliqués sont
plus partie prenante dans la formation
qui sont en train de licencier
j'apprends un marché laminé ly
finalement brune voire trois composantes
y voir trois interprétations différentes
on peut y voir d'une part le bébé qui va
naître à l'arraché on peut y voir la
société qui elle doit faire face à ces
nouveautés pour cette révolution est
idoine elle même à prendre elles mêmes
leur ville chan china vanke de s'adapter
à cette révolution
les jambes et on trouve aussi le
numérique comme porte ouverte vers quant
à de nouvelles façons d'enseigner tas de
nouveautés pédagogiques
mais est ce que finalement comme on le
voit au travers de cette présentation on
en parle ou trois façons d'interpréter
ce titre qui convergent idéal pour mot
ce que doit être l'éducation tournon
merci à vous